for the month of May first we feast
teamed up with the world-famous cocktail
bar PDT in New York City to create the
hot dog sessions we've brought together
some of our favorite chefs and musicians
including Action Bronson Michael White
and Andrew Carmellini
to collaborate on limited-edition hot
dogs each available exclusively at PDT
for one week only hi everybody I'm April
Bloomfield from the Spotted Pig in New
York City and this is Estelle singer all
that good stuff and this is first we
feast hot submissions
so first we feast also start with a
special hot dog collaboration and so
we've got a phone kind of met we just
figured like to British people we get it
good
so I learnt that you have to make the
routes I have West Indian request it yes
Western hear me you know you you
mentioned barbecue sauce as well as like
West Indian food so I was like we could
do a take on like a jerk barbecue sauce
so that's what we did but you know like
scotch bonnets and pretty spicy yeah
take over the world they do but they
delicious and they deserve to take over
they do but so we made two kinds of
pickles just to kind of cut through that
spiciness once a mayonnaise jar Denair
which is an Italian pickle which I'm
very passionate about Italian food so I
thought we could pay Italian with
Jamaica nice so he might work first time
trying it so these are lovely little hot
dogs so I'm gonna go with a little bit
of this
barbecued scotch on it yeah nice might
want to go a little easy on that and
then while you reckon you want to try
some of this crease that the mayonnaise
or the creme fraiche you know yeah
exactly so we'll just add a little bit
of that so in here there's onions
there's a little like you know market
veg your broker cauliflower there so
it's all nice and pickling and it'll cut
for me and then I've got some if we're
brave announcer actual scotch bonnet we
gotta find shall we go see let's try it
but if dangerous me yeah you know maybe
not too many all right and then I got
some spring onions I think maybe just
like onions I say whatever you can't not
have onions and so then we got some
likes lovely spring onions
right up you wanna have fun I find a
wonderful look at it nice awesome you
get first and then maybe we'll try the
one with their maintenance okay here we
go
that was a terrible drug it's good that
you spice it hot if I see how yummy mmm
it's got the best hotdog ever goes in
what else about the water mmm this is
wonderful
perfect mm-hmm right the pickle works
really well it does it cause it girl
cause it down is what we could call it
West Indian god I'd like to call her
that first Jordanaires garden in Italian
and what stealing bits yeah well this
kind of that works out gorgeous
garnish flower life we should just call
it gorgeous garnish
you